who've taken a 12-2 lead here early on
white over Williams nice play stems the
time
[Music]
pelicans get it right back none I knew
what good you know the numbers have
probably changed but as of a couple of
seasons ago tried to make the right play
there's no way he was gonna block that
right no no as a coach I would have been
upset if he wouldn't have came while
they went them
throw the ball back but a thousand times
a night on time that will will be and
that is unfortunate so if he ever if
anybody ever doubt that he played in
Hell in Las Vegas summer league white
pushes for Chicago he'll do it himself
back-to-back threes for Kobe white the
rookie has the feeling sub this is the
one before early in the game he tried to
force that get to the basket turn the
ball over there didn't have anybody
running with him
Kobe white behind the back that's what
you want to see hangs it hits Evander
cashes in with the three rookies showing
their stuff all over the place here at
Thomas and Mack 21 now for the rookie
Nikhil Alexander Walker the Canadian
from Virginia Tech
finish my white Metall be a delay of
game penalty or a technical foul perhaps
Alexander Walker and Hayes have been
tracking each other in terms of points
they're both at 23 against you know what
it looks like to me without less hehe
noticing that word like he's free down
it's like he was just like he was caved
in college and now getting to the NBA
he's free to express himself and play
the type of game he's always wanted over
is wrong absolutely that's what he's
done to that pass here every time
they'll stop mr. play you look at the
code